And these simulations for harvesting fish, you see several situations
in which the amount of fish stays constant.
You could say the falls up and the falls down exactly balance each other.
This has caused an equilibrium or steady state or fixed point.
These three terms are almost interchangeable. I'm going to use the term equilibrium.
In most cases, equilibria can be classified as either stable or unstable
even though in some cases you may have a mixed form.
This position at the bottom of the valley is a stable equilibrium.
If you start close to it, you will end up at that position.
This position on top of the hill is an unstable equilibrium.
If you happen to be in this precised spot, you are going to stay there,
but if you're off just by a little, you're going to roll down the hill.